[Musica]
e il 2015 sono nel palazzetto di
Fiumicino Roma si gioca una gara molto
importante è una gara di Serie A2 di
calcio a 5
nella Terna sono l'arbitro più esperto
il fattore emotivo è sotto controllo
vicino a me a pochi metri pochissimi
metri c'è il pubblico ci sono i tifosi e
io sento il loro fiato sul collo
dodicesimo minuto del primo tempo parte
un'azione molto veloce
l'attaccante del Fiumicino Prende il
pallone e si invola verso la porta
avversaria il portiere dall'altra parte
comprende il pericolo e va incontro
all'attaccante
metà campo fallo netto
in quel momento
il delirio
succede che nella frazione di secondo
successiva al mio fischio il pallone
finisca tra i piedi del compagno
dell'attaccante del Fiumicino che tira
una sassata e Segna un gol spettacolare
ho commesso un errore perché una volta
che l'arbitro fischia non può più
tornare indietro
e quindi ho commesso un gravissimo
errore
ho commesso un errore talmente tanto
clamoroso che la federazione arbitrale
internazionale della Fifa ha preso
questo mio errore per mostrarlo a
migliaia di arbitri nel mondo per far
vedere cosa non fare in una situazione
simile
io emotivamente ero distrutta
non sapevo come poter andare avanti
in campo se un calciatore sbaglia può
essere sostituito
l'arbitro no l'arbitro deve portare
avanti la partita fino alla fine anche
se sbaglia
e quindi in quel momento
sentivo un fuoco
ardermide dentro mi bruciava
quell'errore ma dovevo andare avanti
dovevo proseguire quella partita gara
importante
come come potevo fare dovevo venirne
fuori
L'unica cosa che potevo fare per venire
fuori da una situazione del genere da
una situazione così difficile
era perdonarmi
perdonarmi è stata la mia salvezza
perché in quel momento quando ho
fischiato sono passata dall'essere
dall'avere la testa alta il petto in
fuori a sentirmi un palloncino sgonfio
con la testa in giù le spalle piegate in
ginocchio
però dobbiamo andare avanti
E così ho fatto e ho iniziato dalla mia
postura ho fatto
un bel respiro ho rialzato la testa
ho tirato le spalle su e ho ripreso ho
ripreso la partita
Ho tirato fuori quella tenacia che ho
sempre avuto ma che i momenti di
pericolo i momenti così difficili ti
accorgi di avere ed è quella che ti
spinge ad andare avanti
da quella partita son venuta fuori
perdonata
e ammaccata
però perdonata soprattutto da me stessa
quell'errore me l'ero lasciato alle
spalle e quindi il fatto di essermi
perdonata è stato vincente mi ha aiutato
Io penso che
arbitrare sia un po' la metafora della
vita perché se ci pensiamo bene tutti
noi ogni giorno
abbiamo
prendiamo tantissime decisioni
ognuno di noi ogni giorno
ha tantissime decisioni da prendere
Molte sono semplici come per esempio
vado in ufficio
a piedi vado in ufficio in auto Oppure
cosa indosso oggi
però ci sono anche delle decisioni
importanti della nostra vita quelle che
ci cambiano la vita
per esempio
Le chiedo di sposarmi oppure è il
momento di avere un figlio
o ancora
che faccio la compro questa casa anche
se devo pagare un mutuo magari per 30
anni
non lo so io non ho una soluzione
però se è vero che a volte nella vita
abbiamo più tempo per decidere rispetto
ai pochi secondi che ha l'arbitro non è
detto che facciamo sempre
la scelta giusta non è vero non è sempre
vero che decidiamo Quello che è sempre
corretto per noi
quando io sbaglio
ho tante soluzioni
e io non ho la
non ho la scelta non ho la risposta
giusta la risposta giusta da darvi però
posso darvi
Posso proporvi la mia esperienza cioè
quello che faccio io ogni volta che
sbaglio ed è qualcosa che ho ripreso dal
mio sport dai tanti anni che io ho
passato in giro per i campi d'Italia e
io quando sbaglio accolgo il mio errore
Anche se un errore che mi brucia io
questo mio errore non lo difendo ma lo
accetto lo ammetto e mi perdono
un'altra cosa che faccio per superare il
mio errore per andare avanti
reagisco cioè tiro fuori tutta la
tenacia la voglia di riscatto e riprendo
dalla postura mi rimetto con la testa
alta e spalle in fuori E ricomincio
sgombro la mente dai pensieri negativi
dai pensieri tossici ma mi metto in
assetto e riparto
infine quando sbaglio
trovo le mie soluzioni
Cioè
metto a fuoco l'errore
e nel calcio come nella vita
c'è un regolamento Sì però questo
regolamento va va interpretato e quindi
quando io sbaglio Cerco le mie soluzioni
Cosa posso fare come posso andare avanti
e infine ragionando
cercando le mie soluzioni
[Musica]
è bello godersi la soddisfazione di
averle trovate
[Applauso]
[Musica]